bello sto menu bella questi ragazzi è
pervenuti a un menù veramente brutto ma
il gioco non credo che sia l'europa che
abbia un senso perché il titolo dice
notte uno quindi già un po di vice faina
del freddo
la baby sitter è ora di andare a letto
il bambino è questo quello che pensi il
bambino in giallo atto uno scena due o
kay teso cosa facciamo qua io sono la
baby sitter quello chiamiamo stamani
occhi eccelsi sei veramente bello allora
ti chiamerò lucifer bene a questo gioco
incredibile io posso prendere il bambino
e sballo tarlo in giro c'è ma che gioco
pazzesco all'asta in attimo qua che
arrivò stati stai qua perfetta aspetta
che voglio vedere un attimo se posso
prendere qualsiasi oggetto no il bambino
però lo posso prendere bellissimo sto
gioco dove mi hai messo a essere umano
inferiore noi ci guarda dall'alto al
baida da tim burton e conquistare il
mondo scusa se ho dato tutto a posto con
la testa non volevo assolutamente fare
tutto ciò è il gioco che me l'ha fatto
ora bagnetto bagnetto bagnetto
innanzitutto ci mettiamo qua prendo un
attimo la nuovi dica qualcosa per
cambiarti ferma un attimo allora
prendiamo qua ci metto come non lo devo
fare secondo me lo devo fare più avanti
allora non andiamo avanti degli
obiettivi allora andiamo subito in
cucina perché devo prendere la bottiglia
dal frigo da un attimo sul bambino sul
forno
perfetto ecco qua lucifer sulla tua
finta baby ti sei cagato addosso
e allora su punto io direi di portarlo
al cambiato io come si chiama aspetta
che non mi ricordo il nome di questa
cosa
no no scusa non volevo scala che hanno
cambiato che ha posto
prendi un nuovo pannolino eccolo qua
qualcosa non sta funzionando ma per ora
non è che poi andate in giro per casa
come vuoi mentre io prendo il pannolino
fi quella faccia ti sei cagato addosso e
pure colpa mia lo so io c'è una perfetta
non sei più contento lo vedo triste ma
perché sei triste non è servita a the
club e bijoux de ven
dov'è che la tua camera da letto tesoro
lucifer come stai giochiamo così loro
che gli occhi insomma dice no a questo è
il tuo bellissimo letto matrimoniale
fantastico o right to the lights out
guaracha i giochini qua
volendo ai anche libro che ti insegna
come sognare come un re volume 2 hai
tutto tesoro buon
buonanotte ma vado a dormire anch'io
devo spegnerlo si scusi scusi scusi la
luce sta qua non c'è l'inter lo piccolo
perfetto notte a posto c'è la out on the
top
ho finalmente la bellissima puntata di
ulisse con alberto sono almeno una sera
[Musica]
stamane che non ho figli va bene arrivo
arrivo capito non piangere adesso dice
ti leggo io lì come vecchi e fatta per
la porta tesoro dove ma cosa ci fai qua
come i fatti come hai fatto ma non
ridere non ri allora ti devo portare di
nuovo a dormire era successa una roba
bruttissima sto guardando temptation
island tesoro per favore dai e va bene
tutto però è dormi domani ti cambi di
nuovo il pannolino promesso
no perché non me la conta giusta questo
è a aa a aa posto tocca rimasti non so
tempi shona lowe alberto angela io
andrei visto la qualità del gioco su
alberto angela questo perché il gioco è
fatto bene notte due il bambino ridendo
guarda guarda non è divertente la sitter
che ho detto di non farlo
atto ii scena uno per questo è
meraviglioso
smettila di invocare il demonio e per
cortesia fai le cose fatte bene magari
fosse stata tutta la vita sto bambino
maledetto o brevi tour c'è in tema o sei
brutto basta provi goduria e fare cose
del genere farvi capire cosa è successo
a porco demonio da dove aimés eccolo qua
vicino al talismano il talismano e loro
utilizzo nella cura dei bambini
ok lo leggiamo un'altra volta non me non
farmi bestiali re cambiato il pannolino
quando si cade addosso un casino
cambiati da solo dito non si ferma
allora allora la vogliamo smettere di
fare quello che vogliamo andiamo a
dormire si ascolta la babysitter
maledizione ma inizio a vedi mai un
giorno come mi stai guardando ma che è
stato fatto
let's go o finalmente come mi ha detto
vediamo se tradisce la sua tipa o
viceversa non ha pianto non ha pianto
tesoro come siamo che è successo qua va
bene le presine al posto delle mani ma
cos'è sta roba
tornerai tout dormi che c'è the passion
island dove incise tosti figghiu ok lo
stai calmo amore hai comprato ancora
prolunga per il frigo e amore hai chiuso
tu la porta del frigo è tutto
[Musica]
non ho mai visto uno sguardo così nei
miei confronti tranne quando ho guardato
mars attacks quei film sugli alieni
allora è quello che vuoi lucifer mangia
bevi tecnico back into the change in
tutti i casi addosso nel mente anche
magi come funziona sta cosa che mi
interessa
allora capiamo un attimo è tutto a posto
prendi il talismano dei geni della
madonna di dio parchi o guarda arrivo è
prendo il test sollecitata beccarmi
jumps chiara in un gioco del genere
talismano per fare i bravi di me
esorcizza il bambino con talismano mi
sembra giusto mi sembra giusto trovare
degli escamotage per fare il uomini
parente parente bello tutto a posto a
quanto pare quindi lo puoi mettere nel
pannolino proprio incorporato perché
dice come certo
tesoro per favore ti prego fantastica
michael non volevo giocare ad auto last
oggi però fa niente
mori 69 2008 amore è preso
hai comprato una prolunga per il suo
canone rai va bene ma non ci voglio
credere
ma che cosa cacchio appena giocato mai
finito e peppiniello il bambino in
giallo
io voglio veramente non credere a quello
che apre ragione il gioco dell'anno
questo ma cos'è spero mi sia piaciuto
lasciato polito e mi piace su come
pensate che io possa migliorare le mie
doti fare italy parente t che io vi
saluto
ci vediamo il servizio di un bacino iss
chiedere che adesso non si lavori
iscritti e noi ci vediamo appunto anno
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]
no